hello everyone and welcome to another
brilliant attacking game from the tata
still chess india rapid tournament you
guys requested a few more games from uh
arjun nerga aces so i thought this one
would be fitting okay his game against
levon from the uh this exact same
tournament is also uh we're showing so
if you guys would enjoy that one as well
now let me know i'm definitely
considering it so let's check it out
like i said brilliant attacking game
features none other than the london
system and we know that when when you
face the london system you have nothing
to worry about but sometimes if you make
even one slight mistake you have a lot
to worry about so let's see what
happened here and why it can be
dangerous uh so it's a game from round
six of this tournament and the arjuna
opens with uh pawn to d4 we have pawn to
d5 knight to f3 knight to f6 uh and of
course bishop to f4 the london system is
on the board uh we have e6 e3 and bishop
to d6 so this is a very standard way of
approaching the london uh bishop to d3
and now well you could capture an f4 in
double white's f pawn this isn't really
anything to worry about this has been
played many times and white
really enjoys this you will put a knight
on e5 and you will have excellent
support for this knight so instead sam
just castles and now knight b to d2
makes sense you want to play pawn to c3
to improve your center as you know the
black will play b6 and c5 to challenge
your center so here black starts with
the b6 you could also start with c5 it's
perfectly fine knight to the e5 and the
now c5 striking in the center we have c3
and we get this standard position that
if you ever face the london or if you
play the london you will get this no
doubt about it where white has this um
incredibly strong knight on e5 and if
you're playing with the black pieces you
will hate it this night with uh you know
your entire being because you will
simply
uh you're just not gonna be able to
handle this in any way it's never good
to capture the knight and it's just so
super annoying so here we have queen to
c7 we put more pressure here we want to
attack the knight even further hopefully
capture it or make it to move but we
know that that's not really happening
queen to f3 by arjun and now comes
knight beat d7 and it makes sense as we
put more pressure on the knight and it
seems now white really has to react to
this move uh but this isn't the precise
way to uh counter this line of the
london system there is a game that was
played in 2018 world rapid championship
between andrew tang and magnus carlson
uh this exact same position was on the
board and magnus played bishop to a6 and
this move uh pretty much uh
completely uh
well removes white's attack from the
table
because there's no way to avoid the the
exchange of light square bishops for
example if you try something like bishop
to c2 to keep uh
to keep your attacking chances alive
then you allow this c captures on d4 and
now you can't capture with the c pawn
because the bishop hangs and if you play
e captures on d4 now we just play knight
to c6 and now we've uh we have an
excellent square for a knight we're
putting more pressure on the e5 knight
and white just doesn't have time to
organize any sort of an attack if you
capture on c6 for example bishop
captures an f4 you trade everything off
let's say knight b4 attacks the bishop
but now even bishop captures with czech
king captures and we play bishop b7 or
bishop to c4 it's all perfectly fine and
white's attack is over this knight is a
brilliant defender there's nothing to
worry about black is definitely better
here so what you would have to do after
this bishop to a6 is just capture it
there's really nothing better like
it happened in the game and now just
knight captures an a6 point being that
now if white continues with the attack
of course h4 h5 is very very scary black
now has c captures on d4 and after e
captures even this knight to c5 the pawn
on d4 is uh overloaded and you cannot
attack here and defend here at the same
time so either you capture and then we
pick up the knight on e5 that's
fine for black or if you don't this
knight is coming to e4 and black sold
all of his problems so bishop a6 a move
to remember if you play this um
against the london system but uh
shanklin played knight b37 and this is
now a problem yes you are attacking this
three times but it's very easy to
counter this just queen g3 and now you
are uh adding another piece into the
attack while defending this e5 square
and it's never good to capture here for
example knight captures we're gonna play
d captures black loses a piece and even
if you try bishop captures the captures
is very annoying the knight has to move
somewhere it's well no square is
really good for example knight here
queen here you can't capture the the h7
square is hanging uh it's just very very
uh ugly to play for black so instead
after queen g3 we have knight to e8 now
the knight is defending on g7 you can
bring the other knight to f6 uh and now
comes knight d to f3 i'm just adding
another defender here and mounting the
attack even though okay this is a rapid
game so you don't have all that much
time but queen to h4 was much much
deadlier here uh you just go after the
h7 pawn and after
black's black defense this lets an id to
f6 now there's g4 and that's it g5 is
coming uh how do you defend against g5
you're gonna kick away the defender of
the h7 square you're gonna have to play
g6 bishop h6 and black can resign this
uh so after knight to e8 okay knight d
to f3 was played it's a rapid game uh
now comes c capture sunday for c
captures and now would you play you've
managed to eliminate some of the tension
uh in the center but it's still hard to
even find the move and here you really
should continue with knight d to f6 and
just try to hold on there's no way to
remove this knight from e5 and this game
again will perfectly show you why so
here sam tries to pick up this knight he
plays bishop captures on e5 but i know
you guys have heard of poison pawns but
this is a in the london system this is a
poisoned knight
and now comes d captures an e5 not even
bishop captures or knight captures d
captures an e5 and look at the position
now the pawn on e5 is uh paralyzing
blacks entire half of the board the
knights cannot move the queen does
nothing the the rooks are unable to join
the game and the bishop really doesn't
have all that much to do you you can
develop it here but it's not really
doing all that much this is impossible
bishop covers a6 so there's no good move
here for black sam tried g6 but now just
castles white position is so good that
white doesn't even have to
hurry up with anything he can castle to
safety and then maybe we're going to
start pushing our h pawn all depending
on what black plays here we have knight
c5 going after the bishop but this only
helps white develop so arjun plays rook
the c1 now the knight cannot move or
also we're threatening to just win the
knight
and here a5 preventing b4 now comes
queen to h4 the queen is now occupying
the dark squares knight to g5 will be
well very very unpleasant for black
and finally as the a6 square is now
available to black bishop to a6 we want
to remove this defender from the d3
square but now
the game is just winning for white and
well sam uh is unable to prevent this
regardless of what he plays so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the idea uh
the disposition while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this well
unstoppable attack and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course uh bishop captures an a6 uh we
have to start with this uh just to get
rid of the the hanging bishop on d3 but
the actual move that you guys saw is the
one that follows we have rook captures
on a6 and now of course g4 that's the
key move we are stopping h5 and now
there is nothing um
uh
there's nothing uh for black to do here
bishop h6 right away you can block with
knight to g7 so it's not as impressive
but the g4
black is you know just the breath of any
counter play and here knight to g7 was
played by sam but now queen h6 and he
was in this position on move at 19 that
sam shanklin resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
it's uh knight g5 is coming you you will
not be able to defend the h7 square uh
or you will be but you have to give up
material now to try and do so you have
to play knight back to e8 then after
knight g5 you have to play f5 or f6 uh
so the queen defends the h7 square we're
going to play e captures on f6 alpha
song
opening up an attack towards the black
queen and once the queen moves somewhere
we're going to play f7 check and that's
it
rook will capture knight will capture
and black is completely busted here
there's not
not much for black to do here uh
not only that your position is terrible
you're down in material and the white
has a very clear way of what he wants to
do you have a rook on the f file you
want to play f3e4 you want to play h4h5
and slowly but surely black's position
will just uh you know continue to
deteriorate until it crumbles
so yeah after this queen to h6 move sam
resigned and what a spectacular victory
for arjun ergasi uh in round six of the
tata still india edition uh the the
rapid one uh so i hope you guys enjoyed
this as i've been receiving a lot of
requests uh for for arjun's games uh as
well he's just improving so much he's an
incredible player and i i can't wait to
see what he does in his next next event
especially a classical one uh so if you
guys would enjoy seeing the the game
against levon
from this
uh tournament uh do uh comment on it and
i will definitely consider it uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and that you've learned something about
how to further counter the london system
if you don't like this i've also made a
tutorial on how to counter the london
system uh but you guys already know that
uh so yeah i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to franco tornello and i
would like to thank me for the best
chess videos andre theron uh nagarjuna
ponogoti and gm sucks rocks for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day